-I want to ask about a video
you posted in Instagram.
Your daughter has
a way of traveling.
-She invented it.
-Yes.
-Well, let's show a clip first,
and then you can explain.
This is her going on a --
-This is how
we move through airports.
And now the V.I.P. way
of moving through hotels.
Who needs a bellhop?
-So, how did she come about
riding on a rolling --
-We got the
little rolling suitcase.
And then she just
figured a way --
She saw it moving and she just
hopped on and got a ride.
And now, like, when we go
through airports or whatever
and you see her,
she just hangs on.
Like, she loves it.
She loves it and, you know,
she wants to do it all the time.
-Yeah.
-People was like,
"You taught her how to do that."
I'm too big to climb
on a suitcase like that.
How could I teach her?
-Does she get excited, then,
when you start to pack up
the suitcases to go on a trip?
Does she know what it means now?
-She doesn't, but the dogs do.
-Oh, yeah.
-You know, Maximus does.
You know, people out there
that have dogs know they --
Max sits in the suitcase.
-Yeah.
-And they give you that
look like --
You know, you just feel so bad.
You know, they got that look.
You're like, "Come on, man.
Don't do this, man.
Don't do this, man."
But, you know, we love them.
And, you know,
dogs love you like nobody else.
-Yeah. It's true.
Even when --
-Oh, yeah.
Let me congratulate you.
I heard you're about
to have another baby.
-Yeah, we're gonna have
our second. Yeah.
-How about that?
-I'm very excited.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Really great.
-Congratulations.
-I'm very excited.
-Yeah, that's beautiful.
-And we think
our son knows it's coming,
but, you know,
it's too hard to tell.
-Well, don't worry about it.
You know, they say
kids are like pancakes.
You mess up the first few.
[ Laughter ]
You're gonna get it.
Just all the stuff you
messed up on the first one,
you'll get better on the second.
-That's good to know.
I'm gonna start calling
my oldest son Pancakes.
And I'll say it's his nickname.
And then, years later,
he'll say, "Why was that?"
And I'll say,
"Let me tell you about Ice-T."
-Yeah. You'll get it right.
You got it right this time.
-So, I want to --
We mentioned "New Jack City."
The casting of that --
This is one of those stories
that's almost
too good to be true.
-Well, I got casted in
a men's bathroom.
-Okay.
-Not like that.
[ Laughs ]
Not -- Nowadays,
you say stuff like that,
people jump all the way.
No. I was in the bathroom
and I'm talking my craziness.
And I said,
"You know, the problem is --"
I'm just ranting to somebody --
"If you could put me
under a microscope
and find one molecule
in me that gave an 'F,'
then they could angle me.
But they can't angle me,
'cause I don't care about
anything," right?
And the director,
Mario Van Peebles,
heard that and said,
"Whoever said that is gonna be
the star of my movie."
And he came out
and he started a conversation,
which I thought he was lying,
but it resulted in
me getting that role.
-Wow.
-Just talking crap
in the crapper.
-If there's anything
that young actors take away,
I hope it's that.
Always such
a pleasure to see you.
Congratulations. Season 19.
-Thank you.